while the r-rated movie Logan the third
film in the solo Wolverine franchise
isn't set to drop until March 3rd 2017
we have a little taste of what's in
store thanks to the first trailer it
sure seems to be inspired by Marvel's
old man Logan comic series but just how
much can we expect Logan to borrow from
these pages here's what you might have
missed in the Logan trailer no more
mutants
Logan was always a reluctant member of
the x-men but underneath it all he may
have needed them more than they needed
him when we see Logan drinking alone at
the cemetery just who is he morning for
know what did you do
browse the world is not the same as it
was
mutants
no gun this hints that Logan might
follow at least one major plot point of
the old man Logan storyline believing
the x-mansion is under siege by a group
of villains Wolverine takes him on
himself and kills them all it's only
after they're all dead that he realizes
he's being tricked and that he's
actually killed the x-men in anguish he
gives up the Wolverine persona and waits
to die in a world mostly devoid of
superheroes it's obviously too soon to
tell whether Logan will follow the
comics but in a mature movie that
promises to be emotional gritty and
takes death seriously a scene depicting
Wolverine slaughter of the x-men would
be unlike anything ever seen in a
superhero movie
x-23 in the trailer our hero was
introduced to a young girl who seems to
have a lot in common with Wolverine
himself
she's like you of time very much like
you this is Laura Kinney also known as
x-23 in the comics her powers are like
Wolverines she has retracting claws and
she can rapidly regenerate so here's our
question will she be Logan's cloned
daughter like she is in the comics or
will he just feel a bond with her over
their shared abilities the trailer
implies that Logan is forced into action
when Laura is kidnapped which is a
complete departure from the old man
Logan series closer to the end of the
trailer Logan has to extend his own
hands fabulous to protect himself
against the claw-like attack evil aura
is demonstrating her fighting skills to
Logan to show him how they're alike or
she's being forced to fight him those
are our best guesses at least Donald
Pierce the main villain of the film is a
cyborg named Donald Pierce an
anti-mutant fanatic with a cybernetic
hand in the comics Pierce has a gang of
fellow cyborgs the Rivas and they go
around hunting down mutants they have a
specific hatred for Wolverine because
sir Eva's became cyborgs after he
chopped off their limbs to be fair most
people would be at least a little puts
out about that to peers but a scratch a
scratch the arms off no it isn't the
Reavers have been confirmed for Logan
and it appears that they're like like a
private security force that works under
Pierce it also seems like Pierce and the
Reavers have some official backing
because they use the self American
Federal Police to go after Logan Laura
and Charles Professor X one big question
about the Logan trailer is why Pierce
seems to kidnap Laura and leave Logan
alive after having him
rounded him restrained this suggests
that could be a much more complex plot
at the heart of Logan what if Pierce has
real target as Charles Xavier
in the comics Pierce captures Charles
and tries to harness his power to hunt
mutants so it's possible that this will
also be a plot point in Logan I'm
coincidentally the mutant Caliban also
figures into Logan who also has the
power to track other mutants we also see
a scene showing guns pointed at Charles
head while he's clearly using his mental
powers as Laura crawls towards him what
if Charles was too difficult to kidnap
so the bad guys took Laura hostage
instead that seems like a convoluted
plot but it would add an emotional
Sophie's Choice element to a film in
which the main character wants to die
funeral for a friend presuming Logan did
kill all the x-men Charles Xavier was
probably able to avoid being killed
because of his abilities as to why
Charles didn't stop the massacre has yet
to be seen but it appears out of
everyone from Logan's old life the only
mutant or living thing that Logan cares
for is Charles at the end of the trailer
we see Wolverine covered in blood and
looking mournfully at the ground while
holding a shovel Logan has killed a lot
of people in his day but he's rarely
taken the time to personally bury anyone
you get one guess of who's taking the
dirt now thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know what
has you most excited about Logan
[Music]